anubis
dog-headed god of the dead thy clawed
hand
stripped blood red taken souls to the
way in scale
watching closely as some win some fail
those that are light to paradise they
proceed but those that are heavy
to omit you feed the feather of my heart
is too light to defy
what is in the soul and to justify so
from that day forth your claws are blood
red
for every human soul you sever from the
mummy dead
anubis hear my plea i beseech thee
my soul is pure and will weigh lightly
tarnish it not with your claws of red
but place it with care
in the place of the heavenly dead
anubis is perhaps one of the most
recognizable gods in the egyptian
pantheon
often we associate him today with the
afterlife and as the god of
mummification
the ancient egyptians first referred to
him as inpu
or anpu the word inpu closely relating
to imp
meaning decay it wasn't until the
arrival of the ancient greeks that he
began to be known
as anubis the iconic appearance of the
god is what makes him so easy to
identify
he was often depicted as a man with the
head of a jackal
and other times he was seen as a regular
jackal or dog that would accompany the
goddess isis
in more recent artwork these two
depictions seem to have been somewhat
merged together
given us a more menacing and mysterious
looking god one that we'd almost expect
as a guardian of the underworld the
association between anubis and the
jackal
is one that was formed because it was
pretty common for egyptian jackals to
lurk around
tombs and graves perhaps one of the main
reasons that tombs became so intricate
and elaborate
was to keep the bodies of the dead safe
from jackals and other animals
the host of genetic research that's been
done over the years would suggest that
the egyptian jackal associated with
anubis is in fact not a jackal at all
but rather an ancient wolf anubis fur
or skin was depicted as black and
jackals typically have brown fur
the colour black was thought to be a
symbol of death but it was also a symbol
of fertility
thought to represent the river nile's
fertile black soil
the first ever mentions of anubis can be
found in the ancient pyramid texts
as well as in some of the ancient tombs
of the old kingdom where he was seen as
the guardian and protector of the dead
after all it was anubis who was
originally considered to be the god of
the underworld
only later he then became associated
with the embalming process and
mummification
when all of the body parts of osiris had
been collected the responsibility of
mummification
fell to anubis a process that had not
been seen before
and one that would provide a model for
all subsequent mummifications to follow
it was believed that when osiris's body
was embalmed and the funeral rights were
ready to be performed
his brother set once again attempted to
attack him this time taking the form of
a leopard
anubis was able to stop the god branding
him in his leopard form with a hot iron
rod
and then flay in his skin wearing the
leopard coat as a warning against anyone
who would dare to defile the bodies of
the dead
it became pretty common practice that
any priest attending to the dead would
wear leopard skin
to celebrate the victory of anubis over
set interestingly enough
the story of anubis brandon set while he
was a leopard is a story that is used to
explain how leopards got their
[Music]
when osiris did eventually pass into the
underworld out of respect for the god
anubis stepped down making osiris the
new ruler
anubis however did maintain a crucial
role helping guide source through to the
afterlife
when a new soul would arrive in the
underworld anubis would escort them to
the hall of two truths where they would
have their heart weighed against a
feather
the feather was thought to represent
mahat the goddess of balance and order
the weighing process was overseen by
anubis and the ceremony was performed in
front of osiris and the judges of the
underworld
the demon known as amit waited by
anubis's side
if the heart weighed heavier than the
feather they would not be granted
passage to the afterlife
they would be given one last chance to
convince osiris and his judges that they
live their fair
and balanced life if they were unable to
do this
then they will be devoured by amit and
cursed to suffer a second death
this entire ceremony led many to refer
to anubis as the guardian of the scales
like many of the other gods in egyptian
mythology anubis's parents were quite an
ambiguous topic
in some accounts it was believed to be
ra and his wife hathur
and in later myths he was believed to be
the son of either osiris or set
there are even links of bastet as a
potential mother because of her
association of perfumed oils
similar to those that would be used
during the embalming process
anubis's wife and put was thought to
represent the female aspect of anubis
in name as well as an association as she
was also seen as a goddess of funeral
and mummification together they had one
child
known as kebachet the goddess of
purification and cool in water
she was often described as the serpent
that purified the pharaoh
many also associated her with the
embalming liquid during the
mummification process
it was even believed that while the
spirits of the dead waited during the
mummification process
kebashet provided them with water to
help purify their souls
most of the individuals involved in the
embalming and mummification process
would worship anubis by wearing masks
that resembled the god during the
embalming ritual
it's believed that anubis possessed a
vast anatomical knowledge because of the
skills he displayed when embalming
bodies
the priests of anubis were regarded as
very skilled healers of a vast knowledge
of herbal
remedies the large popularity of anubis
meant that he was worshipped all over
egypt
and his cult center was in sinopolis
located in upper egypt
the ancient greeks translated this to
mean city of the dog
which ties into anubis close association
with jackals and dogs
[Music]
the ancient greeks drew some interesting
parallels between anubis and the god
hermes
hermes may have been seen as the
messenger of the gods but he did also
play a small role in the underworld
helping guide those to the river styx
and the beginning of their boat journey
they even merged the two gods together
creating a god that would be known as
home anubis
his role was quite similar to that of
anubis and he even took the form of a
man of the head of a jackal
the worship of this variation of anubis
was particularly popular during the
roman rule over egypt
despite how much of a predominant role
anubis had in egyptian mythology
he doesn't really feature in many
stories and i guess we can attribute
this to the difficulty of his task
death isn't exactly something that stops
and all of anubis's time was spent
helping the dead
like many of the other deities
associated with death in anubis we have
a stoic figure who shows complete
devotion to his task
anubis both respects and protects the
dead and he plays an important role in
the underworld
and in that role he remains unbiased and
impartial
trusting that fate will determine the
outcome of the souls that he escorts
the recent depiction of anubis in the tv
show american gods is one that i feel
captures this quite well
anubis is an extremely unselfish god who
cares not for glory or status and we can
clearly see this when he allows osiris
to become the ruler of the underworld
as it does not affect his ability to
protect and help the dead
i hope everyone enjoyed today's video on
anubis if you did then let me know what
you thought in the comments below
i'd like to thank all my patrons who
voted on this week's video this week was
extremely close and anubis did actually
win by just one vote
for those of you interested in
supporting the channel further and
becoming a patron and having a say in
future videos then i'll leave an end
screen and a link in the description for
you guys to click on
but as always i've been your host
mythology and fiction explained
you